montezuma leads the Aztecs in sid
meier's civilization 6 he built the
Aztec capital into one of the greatest
cities in the world Montezuma ordered
the construction of aqueducts and temple
complexes and kept the Aztecs growing
through conquest Montezuma's special
ability is called gifts for the tlatoani
it makes amenities particularly valuable
for this sieve not only do luxuries give
amenities to extra cities but each
different luxury improved in Aztec
territory gives their military more
fighting power Warren amenities are
linked as well in the two logically this
unique building in the entertainment
complex gives amenities faith and great
general points the Aztec unique unit is
the Eagle warrior this powerful version
of the basic warrior unit can turn
defeated enemies into builder units this
ability plays well into the Aztecs
unique ability to use their builders to
speed the construction of districts the
Aztecs are a fantastic sieve for
conquest early in the game the eagle
warrior will give them a strong combat
edge each enemy defeated will be an
opportunity to speed construction of
early districts bringing your cities
online quickly
as you progress through the mid-and late
game the Aztecs can establish extensive
empires by grabbing new luxuries on the
map and using their amenity bonuses to
offset their expansion through military
conquest how will you lead the Aztecs in
Sid Meier's Civilization six
you